فتحت وزارة العدل الآن
تحقيقًا في هذه
المجموعة الواضحة من الوثائق الأمريكية السرية التي
ظهرت على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في
الأسابيع الأخيرة، وتغطي هذه الوثائق
مجموعة واسعة من المواضيع مثل الدعم الأمريكي
لأوكرانيا، ومخاوف المسؤولين الكوريين الجنوبيين
بشأن توفير الذخيرة لأوكرانيا.
الولايات المتحدة التي يمكن بعد ذلك
منحها لأوكرانيا لاستخدامها في
الحرب الأوكرانية.
علاقات الإمارات العربية المتحدة مع روسيا.
معلومات تتعلق بحلفاء الولايات المتحدة
مثل إسرائيل. الآن لا نعرف
مصدر هذه البحيرات ولا يمكننا أيضًا أن نعرفها.
تحقق بشكل مستقل من أن هذه
الوثائق لم يتم تغييرها بطريقة ما،
لكنها تبدو مشابهة للمجموعة
الأولية من الوثائق المتعلقة
بالدعم الأمريكي لأوكرانيا والتي
لفتت الانتباه في وقت سابق من الأسبوع
وأكد المسؤولون الأمريكيون أن هذه
الوثائق تبدو وكأنها  كن حقيقيًا الآن
بالإضافة إلى فتح وزارة العدل
هذا التحقيق،
يقول البنتاغون إنهم ينظرون في الأمر،
والنظر في هذه الوثائق أمر
سريالي جدًا لأنها صور
لقطع من الورق مجعدة
عليها علامات سرية، وبعضها يحمل
سرية للغاية  العلامات التي تعد أعلى
مستوى من التصنيف، يحمل البعض
علامات للمكتب في البنتاغون
الذي يقدم المشورة للرئيس بايدن، ومن
الواضح أن هذا يثير قدرًا كبيرًا من القلق
بين المسؤولين الأمريكيين وخاصة في
البنتاغون كايلي أتوود سي إن إن واشنطن